Michael there are so many people out  there with your background and I guess  they're proud but they're really  I've ever heard of the Romanovs of  course the Russian royal family yes I'm  a descendant I'm a Romanov and you're  just pretending I'll never understand  why people are dressed its history this  is all I wait for the line to continue  you know you think that royal blood  dilutes over time but the poison  survives sometimes I really wonder where  you came from so you ruined her life  because we're from a long line of rich  aspirants you still feel sad in the  middle of this happiness you really are  Russian there was your snobby idea of  what a family looks like what are you  talking about I think I finally  understand why you are the way you are  and let it's not your fault  to the prince and princess is that right  yeah  [Music]  you  you